♪ ("GAME OF THRONES" THEME
PLAYS) ♪
-DIRECTOR:  Rolling!
-(HORSE WHINNYING)
DAVID BENIOFF:  So Jason Momoa,
who plays Khal Drogo came back
for a cameo scene
with Daenerys Targaryen,
played by Emilia.
Jason was one of our favorite
people ever on the show
and very, very strong.
That's not TV make up,
just in real life,
he's just a big, strong dude.
Anyways, we're all out drinking.
D.B. WEISS: 'Cause we were
celebrating,
I mean, we hadn't seen Jason
in a year.
BENIOFF:  Yeah. I'm looking
at Momoa and Momoa's talking
about beating someone
at the slap game
and I'm like, "I'd take you
at the slap game."
WEISS: A chance to beat
Khal Drogo at--
-in a physical contest.
-BENIOFF: Yeah.
WEISS:  Who could pass that up?
BENIOFF:  Exactly, I was like,
"I'm gonna challenge the Khal
because if I beat the Khal,
I'm the Khal."
WEISS:  So David challenges J
to this game,
we've had some beers,
it was like an anesthetic
quantity of beer.
BENIOFF:  So we start going
and I got in
a few pretty good slaps
and then I missed.
And then it was my turn,
so I put my hands out
and he starts slapping.
WEISS:  I was looking at someone
else, probably Emilia, or Alfie,
who was sitting next to her.
I was looking at them.
In the background,
there's just this...
-(GRUNTING)
-(SLAPPING)
WEISS:  After about 10 of them,
you realize that
it hasn't stopped.
BENIOFF:
Problem was he wasn't missing.
WEISS:  And your conversation
has been going on with this,
kind of, firecracker sound
going off and I looked over
and his hands were bright red
and he was still going.
And that was when all of us
decided to put our conversation
on hold and to watch
this contest.
BENIOFF:  Yeah. I looked
in Momoa's eyes,
I saw no mercy there.
But I wouldn't quit because,
you know, I had my pride,
I had my dumb pride.
WEISS:  My hands hurt to even
think about this.
BENIOFF:  Emilia was the first
to point out the hands.
WEISS: Yeah. When we looked down
to his hands,
his hands didn't look right.
His hands were a lot bigger
than his hands normally are.
BENIOFF:  But you know,
I just thought it was one
of those things where it's like,
it looks pretty bad.
Yes, they look like catcher's
mitts with bubonic plague
on them but it's gonna be better
tomorrow.
WEISS:  So I told Jason, "I thin
you-- I think you won this one."
BENIOFF:  So the morning after
the slap game,
I woke up in my bed in Belfast
and my hands had doubled
in size overnight.
And they now were
truly ludicrous.
And I had to get on a plane
and fly back to Los Angeles,
so I did and I flew back with
my dumb catcher's mitt hands.
And I finally got home
after this long flight
and walked up to my doorway
and there was my wife
and our baby girl,
and she saw me and I was
kind of trying to hide
my hands a little bit.
But it didn't work 'cause they
were so monstrous and she said,
"You're going to the hospital."
And she drove me down
to the emergency room,
since I couldn't drive.
We waited for the doctor
and finally she saw us
and she looked at them
and she said, "What happened?"
And I said, "I played
the slap game with Jason Momoa."
And then she said,
"Okay, let's do some X-rays."
And she came back
and her diagnosis was that
Jason Momoa had squished
my hands.
WEISS:  They got squished.
BENIOFF: So it just goes to show
don't challenge the Khal.
(TV STATIC)